hello and welcome to a week 16 edition
of The Bleacher Report fantasy football
show presented by State Farm my name is
Adam Levitan each and every week joined
here by Michael Leone to get you set for
fantasy football here in fantasy
semifinal week Michael tell the people
what ridiculous Jersey you're wearing
today and how's it
going you know the uh we got the Saints
Rams game tonight so I have an Isaac
Bruce throwback jersey to uh honor
tonight's battle for the uh last spot on
the NFC Wild Card race uh you are aware
that no one watching this actually knows
who Isaac Bruce is
correct yes they do there's some Boomers
out there with
me okay anyways on today's show we are
going to go through some of our favorite
starts for the week some of our favorite
sits for the week I think we're going to
hit some bundles as well and of course
we'll get to as many of your chat
questions as possible being that
Christmas is coming up on
Monday be sure you watch closely for
some Christmas
themed Graphics here and fun today I
wait for people to get in here though
let's take some questions first for PF
genz says Curtis Samuel or jacobe Meyers
very difficult matchup here for Curtis
Samuel against one of the NFL's best
pass defenses we did see Tu of aloa and
the Dolphins uh pass game get loose
without Tyreek Hill against this Jets
defense last week so it's not completely
dead but yeah Le any thoughts on CES Sam
versus Kobe Meyers this week yeah that's
a tough one we've got both projected
around like 10 PPR points I think I'm
going to go Curtis Samuel just seems
like he's been a little bit more
consistent and you know Washington's
going to throw pretty much no matter
what whereas jacobe Meyers the target
share just has hasn't been as good since
they switched from Jimmy G to Aiden
oconnell and that's pretty much stuck
doesn't have a lot of games hitting you
know a 20% or higher Target share a lot
of games in the low team so yeah give me
Curtis Samuel there but it's very close
uh Patrick Mahomes son is in the chat
actually shout out to Patrick Mahomes
son says Jared Goff or Lamar Jackson
this week I understand it's a difficult
spot for Lamar Jackson against San
Francisco it is such a big game on
Christmas night I think Lamar will be
ready to play and I just I can't bench a
guy who can throw three touchdowns and
run for 100 yards in the same game I I
just can't bench him so it' be Lamar for
me any disagreement there uh Leone no no
disagreement for me uh mahomes's son you
know since it's mahomes's son we answer
two questions from him but only you know
giving him the VIP treatment asks higgy
or Waller this week uh if you got to
make that decision tonight I think I
would play Waller and lean the upside a
little bit more uncertainty worst case I
think these two are coin flip but best
case Waller's role continues to grow
second week back um yeah so Darren
waller for me yeah I think so too
higgy's had some really poor games even
when he's been healthy here this will be
his second game back for Tyler higgy
here tonight against I think an
underrated Saints defense Hy says panua
or Chris alve here we go with the
hashtag how rich two very very good
options here tonight pukan niku is you
know not that far off of Cooper cup and
his underlying stats Chris alave has
been sick been hurt seems like he's
going to be healthy
tonight my gut is puka here at home as a
guy who's been more consistent with his
Target shares this year and really like
not just Target shares you know I know
Chris laes had an incredible amount of
air yards a lot of prairie yards in
there for Chris alve as well so I like
alve tonight but I think I'd go puka
there Leon
thoughts yeah I just think you know if
it's close give me the guy who's
healthier the guy on the team with the
higher team total you know both those
tiebreakers swing the way of Puka so I
would play him over a la even though
obviously both are very good
starts oh right let's get into the
featured segment of today's show which
is going to be a nice or naughty list as
you might imagine nice means we like
them this week naughty means we don't
like them
this
week let's start off with jayen Warren
home game for Jaylen Warren against the
Bengals I'm not sure people really
realize the Cincinnati Bengals might
have the worst defense in the NFL and
like all around you know and you can
make a case that Washington's pass
defense is worse but all around the
Bengals might have the worst defense in
the entire NFL they'll be starting Mason
Rudolph here in this game will Steelers
and so you get into a spot on Jaylen
Warren where they could fall behind
which is better for Jaylen Warren he
plays more than Nai when they fall
behind and when he gets touches it's
against the worst defense in the league
so Jaylen Warren's been on the border my
son actually has Jaylen Warren on his
fantasy team he's always trying to
decide whether to start him or not I
think there a spot where I would start
Jaylen Warren and therefore putting him
on the nice
list
presents are falling from the sky Leon
and we got a ho ho ho in there as well
hope you guys caught that yeah presents
for Jaylen Warren I'll go to the next
guy on our list which is Noah Brown who
had a strong game last week with Case
Keenum at the helm had a 31% Target
share you know separating from the rest
of the Houston wide receivers with Nico
Collins out but this week pretty tough
matchup for Houston they're gonna be
without Stroud again once again have to
play Case Keenum and they're going up
against the Cleveland defense that is
one of the best in the entire league uh
last week was a little bit easier
against the Tennessee pass defense
that's not so strong there's also a
small chance that Nico Collins returns
this week so even if he doesn't I don't
like Noah Brown on the matchup but
especially if Nico Collins is back we're
gonna put Noah Brown on the naughty
list Cole for Noah Brown cole in the
stocking for Noah Brown
God I got buried by Noah Brown last week
in a in a head-to-head and God that was
so frustrating anyways anyways nobody
cares let's go to uh a couple chats here
CCD says Gino Smith or Matthew Stafford
so of course youo Smith almost seemed
like he was gonna play in the game last
week did not end up playing think he is
will almost certainly be back this week
will will Gino meanwhile you get Matthew
Stafford in the game tonight against the
Saints the thing about Gino is that jsn
is coming on DK mchf is healthy Tyler
Lockett is healthy they're facing
Tennessee in Tennessee Stafford also has
his weapons healthy so I kind of like
both these guys this week Le I
understand this is a close one what do
you think yeah it's a good spot for both
we have them projected honestly like
nearly identically uh base projection
and ceiling again like complete tossup
so give me Stafford without any of the
health concerns especially since you
have to decide tonight like I don't know
if something came up in practice and
Gino wasn't able to go you'd be in
trouble so you know I don't think you're
giving up any upside and you're taking
some very bad downside scenarios off the
table if you start Stafford tonight yeah
and you have the Dome situation too you
know I mean who knows what the weather's
going to be in Tennessee come Sunday
Andy dton goated says jir Gibbs or
Kenneth Walker oh my God how do these
people have these teams jir Gibbs and
Kenneth Walker have to bench one of them
a difficul is matchup I think for jir
Gibbs here but one way you can beat the
Vikings Blitz is just get it out quick I
mean and get it out quick and hopefully
run some screens and stuff like that I
think that's interesting Kenneth Walker
was awesome in that game on Monday night
against the Eagles I think probably his
best game of the season now it might be
a little different against Tennessee if
he's inefficient and Tennessee has been
very good against the run if he's
inefficient you could see more Zack GB
here against the Titans so my gut is
kind of jir Gibbs here but a lot depends
on how much you think Kenneth Walker
split off Zack shanet from last week
will be sticky so tough one here Leon
I'll go Gibbs but what do you
think yeah I'm gonna go Gibbs I just
think he's shown to be so explosive and
there's less ways he gets game scripted
out than Kenneth Walker so I prefer him
Jon asks is Tucker craft a must start
this week Adam I know you were talking
about Tucker craft in our ETR projection
slack Channel and I think he's a very
solid start know solid team total his
Target shares have been double digits
three straight weeks but like any tight
end I do think the floor is probably
lower than the game log suggests it's a
spot where Green Bay could dominate
Carolina and really run a ton and you
might you know a 13 14% Target share
without a whole lot of pass volume
doesn't have a big floor so I think he's
a solid start but I would shy away from
calling him a must start yeah and we're
watching injuries here right like
Christian Watson I would consider
questionable if he's out and Jaden Reed
is out with a toe that would be much
better for Tucker craft in a really good
matchup here coming up against the
Panthers this week D missile says Deon
Anan or Travis etn so I actually think
the best way to beat the Cowboys defense
is to take a very run heavy game plan
very run heavy now I don't a lot of
teams can't do that because they fall
behind by so much against the Cowboys
but you saw what the bills did last week
they got a lead Josh Allen attempted 14
passes or something crazy like that in
the entire game I think that should be
the game plan for Miami if they can get
a lead I don't know if they will I feel
a little bit better about etns role but
God I hate sitting Devon aan in any
setup Leon any thoughts on this
one it's so close uh but I I think
really when anan's healthy you got to
start them I think the upsides too
enormous we also had Rahe moster I
believe missed practice yesterday not
sure you know it could just be a rest
day but keep an eye on that could be
more work for
hn y yeah good point on most dir for
sure all right let's get back to our
nice and naughty list here as we get set
for Christmas on Monday we had Jaylen
Warren on the nice list we had Noah
Brown on the naughty list let's go to
James Connor now James Connor is a guy
who consistently outperforms I think
public
perception this is a tougher spot though
I don't think people realize Bears
defense
since uh they made the trade for Montes
sweat has been very very good and James
Conor has been losing some work to Dem
Marcado and other guys especially in
passing situations so it's kind of a
tough spot I think for James Connor on
the road other guys eating in
defense that's playing better James
Connor is on my naughty list he's been a
bad boy as James
Conor Leon go ahead and take uh the next
one here yeah Stefan Diggs is next on
our list and he's had a disappointing
stretch of games um you know four for 27
against the Jets 4 for 24 against KC
four for 48 against Dallas this last
game had a decent game against Philly
mixed in there another three for 34 game
the last five so for the last five have
kind of been Duds But ultimately he is
still the clear number one wide receiver
for Josh Allen I know the bills went
crazy run heavy last week against Dallas
and it looks like that setup would
happen again this week is Big favorites
against the Chargers but I think they'll
be more neutral in terms of pass right
over expectation and you can really
attack the Chargers any way you want
they have the fif fifth worst pass
defense according to fn's
dvoa and just a little narrative Street
feels like a good squeaky wheel game to
get Stefan Diggs right so I'm going to
put him on my nice
list
Stefan Stefan Diggs gets the presence
the nice list for Steph digs yeah I
mean I could see the Char just Chargers
just laying down and they already have
an atrocious pass defense but I could
definitely see them just laying down
here they are an absolute mess right now
speaking of the Chargers let's get back
to some chats here Mesa says am I the
only one sitting Austin Eckler this week
so I don't think it's crazy to sit
Austin Eckler man but I don't know what
else you'd have that you would sit for
you told me you had jir Gibbs or Kenneth
Walker of course that's fine you can sit
Austin Eckler but yeah there's a lot of
concerns for me on Austin Eckler I think
the high ankle sprain in week one was
has continued to limit him I think when
you play with Easton stick your opport
to make plays in the pass game are
limited when you play with e stick and
without Keenan Allen your touchdown
opportunities are limited so I don't
have a problem with someone sitting
Austin Eckler here on Saturday but yeah
my teams are just always thin at running
back you know but if you had picked up
like a Kiren Williams and then you don't
need Austin Eckler this week I think
that's totally fine totally fine so yeah
you can go ahead with the next chat here
Leone yeah berod asks Trevor Lawrence or
Baker Mayfield going up up against one
another it's kind of crazy that here we
are in week 16 and we've got these guys
projected basically identically Bakers
really come on strong uh Chris Godwin
had his best game of the season last
week and you know you look at Lawrence
he's dealt with some injuries not only
to himself but to his wide receivers and
it's I think it's a toss up really I
might even slide you know towards Baker
here a little bit I think you know the
touchdown upside might be a little bit
higher with the season Mike Evans is
having again I think it's really close
to a coin flip but gut reaction is to go
Baker here yeah two really good matchups
I mean both Jacksonville and Bucks are
getting destroyed through the pass right
now I might go Lawrence for a little bit
more rushing upside I think but
certainly super super close
there all
right let's get into the bundles fantasy
bundles presented by State Farm we
bundling your home and auto insurance is
just another way to save with the
personal price
plan so by bundles we mean teammates
that we think are going to perform well
together that work well together if
anyone plays DFS wants to play DFS we
concentrate on that on that a lot at
establish the run and yes you want to be
stacking you want to have bundles when
you're playing DFS tournaments we'll go
through four of them here that we like
for this week first one is J James Cook
and Josh Allen now James Cook's been
getting there
rushing but ever since Joe Brady took
over they have been throwing the ball to
James Cook at eye opening rates and yeah
it's small sample but it feels like
something shifted there where they were
like listen we need to get James Cook
the ball more we need to get him the
ball more in space and considering that
it's paid off and he's had these huge
games I kind of think it'll continue so
I like Steph digs like we just talked
about I think Gabe Davis is an
interesting guy to have a big game here
a vle guy but a big game here but Josh
Allen and James Cook is probably the one
that I feel best the the stack I feel
best about right now for the
bills Leon any bills uh laundry bro
thoughts and you can go ahead to our
second bundle of the week yeah on the
James Cook
usage it's the looks they're generating
him are really high quality looks for a
running back too I mean he's had the
potential to have you know three longish
Re receiving touchdowns the past four
weeks or so and they're getting him
isolated one-on-one with linebacker so
even if he doesn't get insane amount of
volume in the past game he's getting
like one really high quality look a week
but I will go to the next bundle Justin
fields to Cole Kat this Arizona defense
is really struggling one of the worst in
the entire league and there's been some
good signs for Fields this year you know
I was kind of down on the passing game
for Chicago but since he came back from
injury he's scrambling a little a little
bit less he's taking less sacks he's
getting the ball out quicker that leads
to more pass volume and the total plays
run for Chicago on a weekly basis has
been much higher than it was last year
so those sound like three little things
you might not care about but you add
them all up and that's like four pass
Five pass attempts games more for
Chicago so fields to come at in a spot
where Chicago has one of the highest
team totals you're gonna have all year
yeah love it great spot and we've seen
Fields kind of fail or melt down against
good defenses like Minnesota or
Cleveland he has smashed bad defenses
and certainly Arizona is that third
State Farm bundle of the week is DeAndre
Swift and Eagles defense so people in
Philly have been all over Nick and
Eagles to run the ball more run the ball
more they haven't played well enough to
really get a good run game going through
DeAndre Swift the Giants home against
Giants Tommy DeVito is so likely to fail
I know I know he had that one really fun
Monday night game I think the way he
performed against the Saints is more
likely the Baseline expectation for
DeVito so you get a spot where the
Eagles should have a really big lead
their offensive line should dominate the
Giants front and then you get DeAndre
Swift like it's been frustrating in
fantasy because he doesn't get the one-
yard touchdowns but you can get a big
game here from yardage and hopefully
some touchdowns outside of the one yard
line where you don't get the tush push
stuff so Swift and Eagles defense is a
unique interesting bundle I think this
week Le only go ahead with our last
bundle last one we're going to go to
Minnesota Nick Mullins to Justin
Jefferson and this is a Minnesota team
they're home in a dome slight dogs it's
kind of the good spot for you know still
having a decent amount of Team success
but also the pass volume should be there
for them Detroit's been the middle of
the pack in terms of pass defense and
Nick Mullins will Chuck you know uh we
know this about him for his career he's
at 7.8 yards per attempt which is really
really high you know some of that's a
little inflated by playing some games
with San Francisco but even in the small
sample with Minnesota he's been pretty
solid there and Jefferson couple games
back now from injury expect him to go
off sooner or later I think this is a
really good time to take advantage while
you know the market is still shying away
a little bit
here all
right let's get to some chat
uh we appreciate everyone being here on
this holiday week and so let's get to
some questions El kantu says Cole KT or
Dalton Schultz so really difficult
matchup for Dalton Schultz we just
talked about how strong the matchup is
for Cole KET I think there's a pretty
easy one for me Cole KT really likely to
get some Endzone Targets this week
against Arizona I think and you know
have case keenom against the Browns on
their side as a mess so I will go with
Co KET
here Satchel says Trey McBride or Sam
leaport oh God it's such a weird year
how rich but it's been a weird year at
tight end where you could have actually
picked up McBride and leapa off waivers
and had maybe the two best tight ends
like it's it's crazy you know because
before the year we always talk about oh
you can take Travis Kelce or you can
take Mark Andrew and you separate
there's there's never anything really
available at tight end this year there
has been stuff available late at tight
end and McBride and leap pora are
certainly two of the best so I
understand how people get into this spot
with their teams like I have to decide
between McBride and hackinson this week
I don't want to make that decision but I
have to I have I drafted hackinson and I
picked up McBride so yeah I I understand
anyways Leone I'm rambling McBride or
leapa I mean there's people like me who
early in the season saw Luke Musgrave
and Sam leaport on waivers and was like
I won't put in a bit I'll just take
whichever one's left and takes Luke
Musgrave and it's down super bad but as
far as the PTO verse McBride like it's
an interesting makeup between these two
guys
McBride has a much higher floor because
the targets have been so insane for him
whereas Detroit will be very run heavy
they'll spread the ball around but you
can see leaport constantly when we put
out like our expected fantasy points for
the week at tight end he beats it quite
often because he's getting so many high
quality looks and he's capitalizing on
those scoring a lot of touchdown so I
think it's really close full PPR I'd go
McBride and just take that Target floor
but you know if it's like half PPR
standard that might swing me towards
leaport who definitely has better
touchdown
upside C fritas says two byoa or Brock
pery so not the cleanest of matchups I
think for either one here I just get
concerned that Tua has floor games way
more often than perie does you know I
mean it's even if the Ravens defense
plays well it's hard to see the 49ers
scoring fewer than 20 25 points here so
I I'm a pry guy I love pry generally um
I'll go pry but the only any thoughts
there yeah I think I'll go pery and like
just thinking of the Lamar question too
I know these spots aren't super clean
for Lamar and pie but sometimes the
quarterbacks are asked to do more than
they usually are when it's a tougher
game and just game script might dictate
it so not saying it's a good spot by any
means but that stuff can cancel out a
little bit where you get a little bit
more volume to help offset the
efficiency and we could see that with
pie this week uh edu
matui asks I butchered that uh defense
pick Eagles or Colts Adam I know you
were just hitting on the Philly defense
against the Giants and I think honestly
I think that's pretty clean in favor of
the Eagles just given the insane sack
rate that Tommy DeVito has
shown it's it's like he holds the ball
too long you know he's not polished back
there and they have one of the worst
pass protecting offensive lines in the
league and the Eagles have one of the
best defensive fronts so yeah Eagles
certainly one of the best defensive
starts this week all right let's finish
up with our nice and naughty list here
we'll get back to it with number five
and number five is going to be Terry
McClaren now I know Terry mclen had a
really good game last week probably his
best game of the season if you look at
that game closer a lot of it came very
late when it was Stone Cold garbage time
they had already removed Sam Howell and
they went to jacobe brassett I don't
want to chase that now that they're
playing the Jets you know I didn't see
anything there that made me think oh ter
mcen we can get a 25% Target share from
this week against the Jets I just don't
see it going that way so I'd be worried
about starting McLaren this week from a
matchup and Target share
perspective Terry McClaren has been a
naughty boy this
season okay I will go to Drake London
who's next on our list another wide
receiver here unlike McLaren had a
pretty down week last week he's very
volatile but I think he's different than
someone like say Gabe Davis who's up and
down you never know when to start him
with Drake London we have some idea when
to start him because the issue isn't
Target share we know he's going to get a
really high percentage of his team's
looks it just comes down to what's the
game environment how does that set up
last week set up terribly there was
weather concerns they were playing
against a really bad Carolina team this
week we get them in a dome tight spread
against a Colts team that pushes the
pace I think it's a good spot to you
know play you know Drake London last
week was a bad spot despite him having a
really good week the week before and now
it's totally flipped so don't just rely
on the previous week and get London in
your lineups he is on the nice list
ho ho
ho yeah just to be clear on Drake London
if he was on any other team he'd be like
a household name I mean this dude can
really really play I mean he's got he
just needs to be on a team that is
playing Modern NFL
Football let's go to a few chats real
quick here Ian lusi says Dalton cancade
Hunter Henry or Kyle pittz so Hunter
Henry hurt his knee unfortunately so I
would probably remove him Kyle pittz has
been a mess all year I think that's
pretty easy Dalton cancade there for me
even with dson Knox back dton KC's role
has still been pretty strong so I think
K there pretty easily any disagreement
Leon and then do you want to go to
Gordo no I I think it's pretty close but
I would lean canc in a really good spot
for the bills offense and not overreact
to the goose egg last week Gordo asks
Odell Beckham or Davian wits and that is
a good question we are pretty big wick
stands at ETR had a very strong game
last week but you know again some
concern with the pass volume for Green
Bay as Adam noted Christian Watson kind
of questionable we'll see if he plays or
not so there is some competition for
Targets on a team that might not throw a
lot I know Odell isn't exactly super
high up in terms of pure volume but he's
shown more juice than Rashad baitman
believe it or not and as I talked about
with the San Francisco Baltimore game
this is a spot where Baltimore is
probably going to have to drop back
throw a bit more that volume is good for
the receivers even if the efficiency
drop off hurts the quarterbacks a little
bit
yep Matt says DeAndre Hopkins or Aaron
Jones so on Aaron Jones we have to see
if AJ Dylan's playing if AJ Dylan's out
I would definitely play Aaron Jones here
I think it's close regardless I do have
some concern that Aaron Jones is just
like at the end of the line in terms of
his running back efficiency but I also
have concerns on DeAndre Hopkins in that
last week the Titans were eliminated
from the playoffs and you
know I doubt it actually like it's not
definitely going to go this way but
there's some chance that they're like
well you know we're eliminated from the
playoffs now dandre Hopkins is 30
something years old we'll play him you
know 70% of the routes instead of 100%
of the routes I don't think that's
definitely going to happen but it's at
least possible now they've been
eliminated from the playoffs so I would
probably go Aaron Jones here either way
even though I've been pretty low on
Aaron Jones this season especially
will'll go Aon Jones though if AJ Dylan
misses um yeah any thoughts on that one
Leon you can go to the next
one no I think I'm I'm with you I'd go
Aaron Jones we can go back to the
naughty or nice list number seven here
Bree
Hall and Bree you know had a really
disappointing game last week against the
Dolphins just a tough spot for the Jets
in general I think the pass volume four
for him uh has to come back back up we
saw a lot of success with it two weeks
ago it's a much softer matchup against
Washington they're actually three-point
favorites in this game so hopefully the
rushing game can finally get on track
it's been anemic but it's pretty good
get right spot for the Jets in general
Bree Hall Dynamic player despite the low
yards per carry recently put him on the
nice
list ho ho ho all
right last me of the Naughty or Nice
List is going to be jacobe Meyers as we
mentioned earlier in one of the chat
questions jacobe Myers had some really
nice flashes this year I actually
thought at one point I was like man I'm
glad that I took a bunch of Joey Myers
this year it's been a struggle though
for this team as a whole and now under
Antonio Pierce they're just trying to
get Josh Jacobs 20 plus carries every
game no matter what and now you get a
Chiefs defense which has been very good
against wide receivers this year so you
add it all up Aiden ell going to
Arrowhead it could get real ugly I will
put jacobe Meyers on the naughty
list all right that is going to do it
for our nice and naughty list here ahead
of Christmas guys on the naughty list
AKA guys we don't really like this week
Noah Brown James Connor Terry McClaren
chobe
Meyers guys who have been nice guys we
like this week jillen Warren Steph Diggs
Drake London Breece Hall all
right get to a few chats here before we
get out of here B Smith says is Tamm
Hill a good play tonight oh this is a
sore spot for us Leon as taes Hill a
good play tonight the thing about tames
Hill is that we don't it's really hard
to know when what his role in the game
plan is going to be right really hard to
know and even even when he has a really
good role in the game plan it's often
very touchdown dependent I always argue
that we should have Tamm Hill higher in
our best ball rankings it's hard for me
to say yeah I want to start him here in
season long on a week- toe basis though
so it's tough Leon I thought he was
maybe hurt last week and that was why
the usage was down he had the foot
injury the week before but he's not an
injury report so it's tough to say any
he tastes some Hill thoughts
tonight yeah I mean he's always got a
ton of touchdown upside depending on how
they're going to call play by the goal
line but I'm with you I think the hope
with him is that he was a little bit
banged up maybe not fully healthy last
week you know we might have jumped the
gun with our optimism and it swings back
tonight but I also think it's a spot
where I don't like them as much when
they're playing from behind and they
could be in that spot tonight against
the ram so I don't know pretty pretty
neutral I don't have any hot takes on t
i i yeah given the injury and given that
Kendry Miller is going to be back
tonight and Jamal William is healthy and
Alvin chra is healthy and Chris alve is
healthy they're not like desperate for
tesm game tonight so I wouldn't be that
comfortable starting Tes tonight but you
know if he scores touchdown he's gonna
get there Brandon FR says DK mchf or
Chris olve tonight interesting question
here certainly to Alpha wide receivers
DK meaf has been getting more and more
siphoned off by jsn lately which I like
I mean I love jsn generally any thoughts
on this one Le only DK mcaf versus Chris
alve yeah I'd go Chris alve here I know
again like some health concerns here but
Dome game clear number one wide receiver
and you know with metf still some
questions at quarterback if Gino's gonna
play or not I know lock has filled in
pretty suitably but he's also competing
with jsn with Tyler lock all healthy
right now jsn ascending and you know
they've got the two running backs in
play there too so I just think that you
got a better chance at an alpha game
from malve even though I know we see
those highlight real plays from
DK Matt says Deontay Johnson or Gus
Edwards so two different things going on
here Deontay Johnson will be catching
passes from Mason Rudolph which is scary
Gus Edwards gets a bump from Keaton
Mitchell being out for the year with an
ACL tear but Gus Edwards is going to be
touchdown dependent and he's facing the
49ers which is a tough team to run on
depending on the format I think it was
half PPR or full PPR I might still go
Deontay but anything like less than half
PPR or certainly standard I would go Gus
here any thoughts on this one
Leone yeah I think even half PPR I'd go
Gus I just think this ceiling's a bit
better with the touchdown upside that
he's shown even in a difficult matchup
if they get inside the 5 yard line it's
going to be Gus so um I like him when
both players don't have exactly a great
base
projection gunnet says Kenneth Walker or
bejon Robinson this was actually bejon
thing was one that I flagged for our
projections team to look at because even
before bejan's fumble last week he only
had 11 opportunities alir had 11
opportunities and cat had six and you
know we're just at the point where I'm
so sick and tired of playing beon and
watching these other guys get work that
said we already talked about the
problems with Kenneth Walker this week
if he doesn't play as well if he falls
if they fall behind you're going to see
Zack shanet so I'm pretty sure we have
beon projected ahead here uh Leon I
probably think it's a little bit closer
than maybe other people do but yeah what
do you think about bejan vers
Walker yeah I think I'd go bejan I just
really like the game environment I know
Atlanta has been frustrating but it did
seem like the overall trend over the
course of the season has been more
towards bejan in a way from aler so uh
it's really such a Do or Die spot I mean
I know we say this like every other week
but arur Smith's got to get the ball the
best players right and you do get
Seattle against the Tennessee run
defense that's pretty good so I prefer
bejan it might be closer than our
current projections but I'd still play
him all right last chat comes from Roman
Roman says Chief's defense or Cowboys
defense Chief's defense is an arrowhead
against the Raiders Cowboys defense is
on the road against the Dolphins I think
Dallas defense has been awesome all year
at creating turnovers and doing big
things with them it's hard to rely on
that I'll just take Kansas City's
defense the one that's at home the one
that's facing
AOC Chiefs defense I think pretty easily
there over Cowboys all
right and in the spirit of the
holidays thank you to everyone it's been
a gift it's been a real
joy for us to be able to do come on here
and do this show mess around have fun
all 2023 NFL season you know what I
might have jumped a gun I'm looking at
my calendar now I actually think we'll
be back
before the 20124 before the calendar
flips to 2024 yes Santa yes so we will
see you one last time in 2023 next week
everybody have a safe and great holiday
enjoy all the games all across all the
days we won't be paying attention to our
families actually we will be deciding
whether Kenneth Walker should have a 63%
Rush share or
62.5% Rush share and that's what we'll
be doing on Christmas so if you want to
check out what we're doing ever you can
head to establish the run.com follow us
on Twitter Adam Levan two hats one Mike
be sure you're following Bleacher Report
and you know who doesn't follow their
favorite insurance provider on Twitter
be sure you're following State Farm on
Twitter also four Leon for all the
people beyond the scenes of Bleacher
Report FB State Farm I am Adam good luck
everybody